foreign
they're dropping like flies who is the
um
the Bitcoin boys oh my goodness the
Bitcoin the Bitcoin Bros are they're
just
they're just dying like
on the vine I don't know what's
happening they're like the dinosaurs so
we're gonna look back it's almost like
um
like they had a bad business model
fake money didn't work or something you
know
I'm gloating a little because I caught
so much hell from you Bitcoin Bros for
the last three years or five years on
how stupid a boomer I am and how out of
touch I am well I'm telling you to stay
away from this crap and now another one
files bankruptcy just a few minutes ago
right oh yeah yeah we had block five
block fi crypto lender block five
follows FTX into bankruptcy and follows
uh four others that file this week into
bankruptcy and it's because it was a
house of cards
Zay is dropping like flies man
it's not it's not it's uh I doubt many
of our listeners had their money tied up
in this kind of crap because they
actually listened to this show uh so I
hope no one out there listening was hurt
by this situation because users are
going to their accounts and it's zero
and they're not getting their money back
in these situations so it's it's a scary
environment if you did throw a bunch of
money into crypto which millions of
people have you remember the old uh
movie It's a Wonderful Life oh yeah
it'll run on the bank yeah you go to get
get your money out and you can't get it
out the bank went broke who knew It's a
Wonderful Life it's it's a modern day
tale yeah I wonder if there's any little
angels with their bells ringing on this
one I'm guessing not I'm guessing
there's some devils doing the dance with
their pitchforks instead uh you gotta
wonder how many more kind of thinking
there's not any dangers involved in this
now could be wrong I mean the guy looks
like Belushi in Animal House
so there's no way that he's yeah
oh actually belushian Animal House as
stoned as he was looks better than this
guy so
um wow that's what happens you don't get
out of the basement often enough for
from fresh air and a haircut
oh man this is a house of cards Dave
truthfully I mean the whole thing is
just crumbling because they were all
intertwined with each other and it turns
out uh it was only worth what people
were willing to pay for it based on hype
instead of based on actual you know
revenues and profits which is what the S
P 500 is based off of well and to recoup
I mean we're gloating and carrying on
and poking fun at you people but we gave
you great intellectual and academic
detail on why this was going to happen
I just truthfully did not think it would
happen at this scale this soon
even that caught me by surprise I
figured it was gonna you know it would
unravel there'd be a few things drop
here or there and eventually the thing
would stabilize and you know over a
period of a decade begin to get some
actual credibility I I thought it would
probably work its way through I don't
know if the whole thing makes it it may
it may just completely cave in I mean
the domino effect on this is because the
I mean well because here's the thing
Rabbi this is an interesting lesson for
everybody not just Bitcoin but about
everything Rabbi Lapin talks about this
book our our good friend he's an
Orthodox Jewish rabbi best-selling book
called thou shall prosper in the book he
looks at money for through the Jewish
lens and he explains to us properly that
money
is not about math money is about trust
money is spiritual
and so that's why all kinds of weird
things have been used as a medium of
exchange throughout history whether it
be a gold bar Wampum that we trade Long
Island for
Furs in the Old West Pioneer Days
you know two beaver pelts why would you
take a a skinned beaver pelt as payment
for something because you trust you
believe that other people will exchange
that for
uh some biscuit dough and some heart
attack right and so you know that you
know you can use anything as a medium of
exchange if you trust that it can be
used to exchange goods in the Old
Testament uh one of the things that was
used was oil
oil was used to keep the holy of holies
the lamps burning in the temple in the
holy of holies and oil was a symbol of
God's spirit was used to anoint Kings
you see the prophets pouring oil over
the top of the head of King David or
King Saul anointing them King and and
oil because it was prized then you could
literally go into the marketplace in
those days with a carafe of oil and do
an exchange and so when the Bible says
in the house of the wise are stores of
choice food and oil it's an indication
of wealth Choice food and oil were
indications of wealth because it was
used for a medium of exchange you can
use
I don't know textiles you could use
anything that's another person would
accept and so it's about trust it's a
spiritual thing money is spiritual and
all money is spiritual uh the dollar
bills no exception it's not magical the
only reason the dollar bill is
um more is more believable has more
credibility is because it's more widely
accepted and has a longer track record
that's all yeah and uh you know backed
by the government and so that that's
where the regulation comes in versus uh
yeah but you have to believe that that
matters we all are in agreement that
this dollar is worth something I I just
I'm really the backing of the government
doesn't even impress me anymore it's
just the idea that I know that I can
take this and go buy a stake with it I
can fill up my car with it well I can't
I can put a few dollars I've put a
little bit of stuff in my car but a
little bit of gas in my car but you know
what I'm saying it's uh and crypto never
really had that it doesn't have a track
record it wasn't volatile it was too
volatile it was too narrowly accepted by
a very narrow portion of the population
um and yet everyone attributed to it the
same
credibility the same spiritual power
that say the dollar or even the peso or
even the Yen has and it's not it was not
there yeah it was a Nuance within the
economy even though it was massive it
was still a Nuance within the world
economy it had not yet proven itself no
it was a a an out of control overgrown
baby child and now it's fallen and
everybody started treating it like it
was a legitimate thing in it and they
got their heads taken off well I kept
telling you don't do that and the
fraudsters and the scammers started to
realize we can make a quick Buck by
entering the space well you know why
they entered the space I mean that's
also spiritual because who was playing
in the space were people looking for
quick easy money and people are looking
for quick easy money are always easy
prey to the con artist
and the scammer and so you're most
easily conned when you're afraid or when
you're a greedy
and um if you're neither of those it's
very hard to con you yeah you're not and
you don't you don't fall for it but get
rich quick man if you're in there going
I got I I I'm cutting edge I'm I'm a
Bitcoin bro man I'm I'm the smartest guy
on the planet and I'm on Tick Tock and
that that proves it right there and I'm
all of this crap and you're setting
yourself up absolutely well I just hope
my next paycheck isn't in Beaver pills
I'm a little worried now Dave what
you're trying to get at here he's trying
to go back to the old times hmm let's
see if he'll take some textiles this
month
oh man George I'm gonna leave at the
break and go hunting that would not
Shock me honestly I'm never killed a
beaver that's why you bought this
property by the woods Dave so you can
take a quick break I can go down there
and make a beaver pill and pay George oh
that's what we're gonna do just go um
you know go down there to the next
segment I'm gonna be Davy Crockett with
this on my head Dave it's gonna be great
he did not wear a beaver pelt George you
were that was a goon skin cap you are so
lame this is the Ramsay show